nous allons débuter notre
audition merci à ceux qui qui sont
présents hein c'est vrai que c'est la
veille du 1er novembre mais on a
l'actualité qui nous mène notamment avec
le pfss bien alors nous allons débuter
nos travaux ce mardi
avec il un retour ouis il y a un
retour
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
merci mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs de de votre accueil don dont
vous avez ouais je sais pas si du coup
il faut mieux parler sans micro ou
si est-ce que c'est mieux oui en tout
cas pour nous ça c'est beaucoup mieux il
y a pas le il y a pas le il y a pas le
retour ouais c'est bon
merci beaucoup pour le confort de tout
le monde je pense que ça sera mieux
comme ça euh effectivement monsieur le
Président vous avez un peu dressé le
tableau de cette de cette audition euh
puisque je vais passer en fait très très
vite sur les éléments mêmes du du
pfss on pourra revenir si vous le
souhaitez sur sur tel tel élément mais
peut-être assez rapidement souligner que
c'est pas pour pour ça qu'il y a pas
d'actualité sur les politiques que dans
la dans la knaf et la branche famille on
on la charge et cette actualité elle
peut passer par d'autres vecteurs et
d'autres canaux que ceux du PLFSS ou
traduire des éléments que vous avez
parfois voter dans le précédent projet
de loi de de financement la sécurité
sociale et
donc il faut pas en traduire et en tirer
la conséquence qu'il y a aucune
actualité encore une fois et aucune
volonté politique qui peut s'exprimer
sur ce sujet bien que de toute façon
vous pourrez en discuter avec les
membres du gouvernement en tant que tel
effectivement le pfss lui-même euh nous
concerne que très ponctuellement et sur
des des éléments de complémentarité
notamment avec l'assurance maladie sur
la C2S notamment sur l'extenction des
publics bénéficiaires et la la
simplification des flux pour ce qui nous
concerne sur ces sujets on a été si vous
regardez le le dossier de presse du du
pdfss on est concerné par des éléments
qui n'ont pas pas finalement trouvé leur
place dans le pdfss lui-même même si ça
participe de la démarche d'ensemble au
titre de la lutte contre la fraude
puisque c'est finalement des mesures
d'ordre réglementaire qui seront
mobilisé notamment sur l'harmonisation
des conditions de résidence des
différentes prestations hein vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des conditions de
résidence sur le territoire national
différencié selon qu'on parle des
prestations familiales 6 mois des
prestations des aides au logement 8 mois
ou du RSA et prestations sociales 9 mois
et donc il va y avoir un alignement
complet à 9 mois d'exigence de résidence
en France mais c'est par le canal
réglementaire que ces mesures seront
traduites mais le le dossier de
presse'en faisait état parce que ça
faisait partie d'une démarche d'ensemble
du plan de lutte contre la fraude
sociale dont d'autres éléments peuvent
être repris dans le dans dans le pdfss
en tant que tel on a d'ailleurs sur les
sujets lutte contre la fraude eu des
éléments d'enrissement dans le débat
parlementaire à l'Assemblée avec la la
création en parallèle de ce qui se fait
dans le projet de loi de finances d'un
délit d'incitation à la fraude sociale
en l'occurrence et on voit qu'il y a ici
ou là des actualités médiatiques ou sur
les réseaux sociaux d'un certain nombre
de personnes qui euh font des formes
d'appel à l'incitation à la fraude et
que il était nécessaire de renforcer
aussi l'arsenal sur ces sujets mais on
est effectivement pas au cœur du
réacteur de de de ce de ce pfss en
lui-même pour autant forte actualité
forte actualité lié on avait pu en
discuter en amont devant votre
commission avec ma présidente que qui
vous salue et qui avait pas
malheureusement pas pu être présente
aujourd'hui euh forte actualité autour
de la convention d'objectif et de
gestion de de la branche amille puisque
puisque vous savez que l'ensemble des
conventions d'objectif et gestion ont
été du régime général ont été renouvelé
et qu'on a pu en juillet valider la
convention d'objectif et de gestion et
le faire dans les conditions assez
favorables avec un large accord de notre
conseil d'administration autour d'une
convention d'objectif de gestion qui est
ambitieuse et sur un certain nombre de
projets que je vais mentionner ensuite
notamment au titre de nos actualités
mais qui se voit dotter d'un certain
nombre de moyens moyens
d'action autour des enjeux d'ffectif des
CAF hein dans des contextes qui peuvent
être parfois difficiles je reviendrai si
vous avez des questions sur sur ces
sujets mais vous vous souvenez que la
réforme des aides au logement avait été
une réforme exigeante pour le réseau des
CAF et qui avait pu se traduire par un
certain nombre de complexité dans le
dans le réseau et puis parce que aussi
nous avons des projets importants à
pororter J reviendrai donc des créations
d'effectifs dans la branche famille ce
qui pas arrivé depuis fort longtemps
dans les conventions d'objectif et de
gestion et puis des moyens important sur
les politiques publiques autour de notre
Fond national d'action sociale euh qui
av ation augmenté de 6 % par an dans la
période plus de plus de 2 milliards on
passe de 6 à 8 milliards entre le début
de la la fin de la précédente convention
objectif 2022 et la fin de C la nouvelle
convention échéance 2027 et notamment
autour de ces plus de milliards il y a
plus 1,5 milliards sur la petite enfance
hein gros enjeux que vous avez croisé
récemment autour du projet de loi plein
emploi du service public de la petite
enfance et de la gouvernance locale
autour de ces services publics de la
petite enfance et du rôle de la branche
famille dans le texte que qui a vocation
à être vootter d'accompagner y compris
financièrement et en conseil les
collectivités locales dans la montée en
puissance de ce service public de la
petite enfance et cet accompagnement
notamment financier il passera par les
moyens de cette convention d'objectif et
des gestion et donc même si le le PLFSS
n'en fait pas mention explicitement il y
a un autre texte qui porte sur le sujet
c'est complètement dans l'actualité
parlementaire et puis c'est complètement
dans l'actualité financière parce que
les moyens qui sont à l'appui de notre
conventionobjectif et gestion ils sont
retracés globalement dans le dans le
pfss donc c'est c'est pour ça que on n
pas besoin de disposition législativ
particulière mais c'est incontournable
et si le vote du PLFSS viendra appuyer
cette dynamique positive en en soutien
des collectivités locales et si vous le
souhaitez dans le débat je pourrais y
revenir mais on est vraiment très engagé
dans ce sujet de de la petite enfance et
le soutien à l'ensemble des acteurs sur
ces sujets à la fois sur le volet
quantitatif pour adapter le volume et le
nombre de place d'accueil et de solution
pour les familles et et sur le volet
qualitatif qui un volet qui est
évidemment très discuté en ce moment et
pour de bonnes raisons et on viendra
aussi apporter notre soutien sur sur ces
sujets et donc petite enfance très
fortement mais aussi enfance jeunesse
parentalité animation de la vie sociale
la nouvelle convention destif et gestion
nous laisse des perspectives positives
et dynamiques sur sur ces sujets qui
sont indispensables contte tenu des
acteurs que nous soutenons dans ces
secteurs de la difficulté parfois
financière de certains de ces acteurs
dans un contexte d'inflation de
difficulté d'attractivité des métiers on
peut en parler sur la petite enfance
mais on peut en parler aussi sur sur les
secteurs de l'animation par exemple et
donc on voit bien que nos enjeux
d'accompagnement des familles de
conciliation de la vie familiale et vie
professionnelle il s'arrête pas à 3 ans
il il continue ensuite autour de la
période scolaire du périscolaire de
l'accompagnement des collectivités sur
sur ces sujets les enjeux de jeunesse
sont très forts et on le voit dans nos
actualités récentes et pas toujours très
très heureuses aussi mais il y a il y a
un accompagnement fort sur ces
thématiques là la présence territoriale
l'animation de la vie sociale les
centres sociaux qui sont sur des
territoires qui sont là aussi fragiles
très nécessaires et notre soutien est je
crois très utile pour que ces espaces
puissent vivre et donc sur tous ces
sujets on a vocation à être au
rendez-vous bien évidemment mais au
rendez-vous de manière plus facilitée
par des moyens financiers qui sont
prévus dans le cadre de cette convention
d'objectifs et de gestion donc ça c'est
une actualité évidemment très forte pour
nous la déclinaison de cette convention
et ces différentes composantes et dans
ces composantes je voudrais citer
quelques projets si vous me permettez
monsieur le Président qui font é y
compris à des votes que vous avez déjà
euh réalisé hein et déjà donné sur des
textes antérieurs mais que voilà nous
sommes chargés de traduire dans dans les
faits avec une actualité forte monsieur
le Président vous connaissez bien le
sujet sur la déconjugalisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé euh
puisque nous avions vous aviez voté euh
à l'été euh 2022 euh cette mesure dans
parmi les mesures d'urgence pour le
pouvoir d'achat euh avec en débat que
nous avions à l'époque sur le délai
d'application euh de cette réforme
ambitieuse et et complexe euh vous aviez
voté une entrée en vigueur à octobre
2023 nous y sommes et les droits
d'octobre seront versés pour la première
fois au 5 novembre dans des conditions
qui je dis avec prudence tant que c'est
pas effectif mais on est totalement
confiant sur la mise en œuvre de cette
réforme la preuve c'est qu'on en parle
pas donc c'est c'est plutôt bon signe
mais je voudrais quand même en parler
parce que c'est quand même un travail
très important qui a été effectué par
les par les équipes en lien avec tous
les acteurs du secteur pour traduire
cette volonté politique très forte qui
s'est exprimée et la traduire finalement
assez rapidement par rapport à ce délai
de mise en place avec le souhait
d'éviter des difficultés pour les
populations et les publics qui sont
concerné qui on attendu cette réforme
depuis longtemps et qui avait droit à
une réforme bien bien conduite et bien
menée avec la complexité que vous
connaissez qui est de mettre en œuvre
cette réforme et d'éviter des perdants
dans cette réforme et donc de mettre en
place un système spécifique pour les
environ 25 30000 on va affiner
maintenant complètement les chiffres
personnes qui auraient pu être perdantes
dans la mise en re de cette réformme et
qui resteront dans ce dispositif de
neutralisation tant qu'elles sont
perdantes au dispositif donc c'est une
réforme pas si simple à mettre en place
et je crois qu'il se met en place dans
des bonnes conditions et ça illustre
aussi le le travail et la mobilisation
des équipes de la CAF et des CAF vous
mentionnez également dans nos
actualités très prochaines la mise en
place normalement au 1er décembre de
l'aide d'urgence aux FEM personnees
victime de violence conjugale je dis
femme parce que c'est évidemment souvent
le cas qui fait éch à la proposition de
loi défendu ici par Valérie lettard et
voté très rapidement et de manière très
consensuelle au Parlement en en début
d'année là aussi avec des délais
relativement brefs de de de mise en
place donc on attend les textes
réglementaires qui permettront de rendre
complètement effective cette entrée en
vigueur en 1er décembre mais pour notre
côté nous sommes préparés évidemment à
faire vivre ce dispositif et ce texte
euh qui doit être important pour donner
cette aide d'urgence dans ces premiers
temps de séparation de d'éloignement du
domicile conjugal pour les femmes
victimes de de violence mentionnez
également toujours au titre des textes
qui sont dansos votre actualité forte
euh tout ça pour vous démentir monsieur
le Président sur le côté il y a pas de
d'actualité sur nos sujets même si c'est
politique familiale au sens large en
l'occurrence puisque c'est le lien avec
le France travail et le projet de loi
sur le plein emploi puisque nous sommes
concernés en 2uxè cercle j'allais dire
mais quand même très fortement par la
gestion du RSA et le lien avec France
travail sur l'inscription de ces publics
et sur la comp accagnement de ces public
et la fuidité qu'il faudra avoir pour
faciliter les parcours des personnes
concernées donc nous sommes parties
prenantes aussi de ce projet dès lors
qu'il aura été voté ce qui
euh se rapproche évidemment avec une
entrée en vigueur prévue en 2000 en 2025
ée en vigueur en 2025 également de la
mesure que vous avez voté dans le
précédent projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale sur le complément
mode de garde avec l'idée que parmi la
logique globale du service public de la
petite enfance l'accès au mode garde
individuel en particulier souffrait d'un
certain nombre d'égalité financière et
de se dire que on devait pouvoir
égaliser les restes à charge selon les
niveaux de revenus des personnes et des
familles quel que soit le mode de garde
qui est choisi et donc faciliter ainsi
les choses et donc c'est quelque chose
qui a votocation rentrer en vigueur làci
en à l'été 202 25 et puis mentionner une
réforme
importante qui est la réforme de la
solidarité à la source et la
modernisation notre délivrance des
prestations du euh RSA et de la prime
d'activité avec l'idée que notre système
de délivrance des prestations est
aujourd'hui particulièrement complexe
parce que les textes sont complexes
parce qu'ils traduisent la complexité
aussi de la vie des diversité des
situations familial professionnelle
d'origine des revenus donc on est en
charge d'appliquer quelque part cette
complexité mais avec le constat qu'on
peut je crois partager qu'aujourd'hui on
fait beaucoup reposer cette complexité
sur les bénéficiaires sur les
allocataures par un système déclaratif
assez lourd puisque tous les trimes est
les personnes doivent n déclarer
l'intégralité de leurs ressources et que
ce faisant beaucoup de nos bénéficiaires
se trompent dans leur déclarations ce
qui objectivement peut pas totalement
leur être reproché vu la complexité de
nos systèmes et donc on est conduit de
notre côté à vérifier contrôler
rectifier faire un certain nombre d'indu
et de rappels ce qui évidemment est
créer une grande instabilité de la
relation financière avec des publics qui
ont précisément besoin de stabilité
financière d'où l'intérêt de cette
réforme d de la solid arité à la source
pour être en mesure progressivement de
dire à allocataires concernés vous
n'avez plus besoin de me déclarer vos
ressources Paris que je je les connais
déjà au moins pour une part d'entre
elles et donc on va simplifier dans un
premier temps les éléments de
déclaration par l'inscription sur la
feuille de paye effective déjà depuis le
1er juillet même si la déclaration sera
obligatoire à partir du 1er janvier
prochain de ce qu'on appelle le montant
not social qui en fait on fait le calcul
à la place des bénéficiaires à
locataires de ce qu' doivent à partir de
le du bas de leur feuille de paye
recomposé comme agrégat déclaratif à la
CAF et objectivement c'est pas facile à
faire donc on le fait à la place et ils
auront à déclaré le montant n sociale
qui est le montant désormais inscrit sur
la feuille de paye et puis dans un
deuxème temps de manière expérimentale
en 2024 et généralisé en 2025 on va
aller vers des déclarations préemplies
comme ça a été fait sur le système
fiscal il y a quelques quelques années
pour que les allocataires n'ai plus
besoin que de vérifier la déclaration
préremplie et de la compléter le cas
échéant par les éléments compl
complémentaire dont ne disposiront pas
complètement sur tous les sur sur toutes
les ressources possibles et donc ce
faisant simplifier beaucoup la vie de
nos allocataires bénéficiaires et
simplifier les allers-retours que nous
pouvons avoir ensemble et éviter des
situations d'indu trop difficile et trop
complexe à à faire pour ces publics qui
sont encore une fois fragiles et donc
dans une logique d'accès au droit de
facilitation une simplification de la
vie de nos bénéficiaires c'est une
réforme très importante très lourde mais
qu'on mène en plusieurs étape et donc
encore une fois expérimentation
généralisation prévu courant 2025 voilà
quelques illustrations de sujets sur
lesquels nous sommes très actif en ce
moment et au-delà du prétexte de
l'examen du du pfss ça me donne
l'occasion devant votre commission
d'apporter ces éléments d'actualité et
de répondre aux questions que vous
pourriez vous poser sur ces sujets ou
sur d'autres sujets naturellement merci
Monsieur le Directeur oui on se rend
bien compte qu' été l'actualité et
l'activité plutôt dense même si en
dehors depfss et je soulligne d'ailleurs
tout particulièrement le travail sur le
la décj jation de la location du
handicapé pour travailler sur le sujet
je maîtrise en toutous les cas je vois
bien la le niveau de complexité du
modèle qui est proposé bien je vais tout
de suite donner la parole à Olivier Hau
ou Elisabeth douanau éisabeth
douanau donc je je prends la main merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
directeur pour rappeler
qu'effectivement vous aviez beaucoup de
dossiers sur la table et en tout cas une
mobilisation qui ne se dément pas pour
mettre en application un certain nombre
de loi ou de réformes qui ont été votées
euh ma
question concerne en fait un sujet qu'on
a déjà abordé la Cour des comptes avait
refusé de certifier vos comptes euh
enfin les comptes de la CAF et de la
branche famille en raison de la
proportion de paiement erronné par
exemple on avait le cas de l'indicateur
à 24 mois les erreurs les erreur à la
hausse ou à la baisse pour les
prestations versées en 2021 c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu ancien mais en
tout cas euh il y a une actualité était
de 7,6 % en en 2021 contre 5,8 % 5,5 %
dans le cas des prestations versées en
2019 donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
faire par des actions qui sont menées
aussi pour éviter un nouveau refus de la
Cour des comptes et en l'occurrence un
dépassement aussi important merci
beaucoup Olivier n oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur
le Président à dans son propos
préliminaire évoquer la quasi absence
des mesures sur le PLFSS alors qu'il a
la baisse des datalité et le modèle
familial qui évolue oui ben je partage
tout à fait ça donc normalement pour une
édition sur le PLFSS et les questions
sont pourtant nombreuses on la posera
d'ailleurs au ministre il y a eu des
annonces sur le le le retour à
l'universalité des allocations
familiales les évolutions sur le congé
parental le complément mode de garde la
c'est en cours mais c'est pour 2025 la
question des ressources humaines aussi
et puis aussi les les régimes
d'autorisation et donc à partir de là
peut-être pas sur cette année même se
pose quand même la la question sur
l'excédent de de la branche famille qui
s'est réduit de 2 milliards d'euros en
2023 par un transfert artificiel de
charg et certaines réformes sont
annoncées je le répète hein comme celle
des congés parentaux tandis que la COG a
prévu une trajectoire financière à la
hausse pour les dépenses du fond
d'action sociale et donc ma question est
la suivante c'est la première
partagez-vous donc ces projections
optimistes du gouvernement quant à la
situation financière de la CAF et puis
sur la nouvelle coge elle prévoit aussi
une hausse significative des dépenses en
faveur des établissements d'accueil du
jeune enfant je pense au barê de la PSU
il a été revu à la hausse de 671 % mais
est-ce que compte tenu de de l'inflation
c'est vraiment une révision à à à à la
hausse ou c'est est-ce que c'est tout
simplement avalé par par l'augmentation
du à l'inflation qui qui entraîne une
augmentation des coût de fonctionnement
et ensuite et
enfin il y a plusieurs ajustements de la
réforme de de la CMG qui ont été adopté
l'année dernière et quelle difficulté
voyez-vous pour la mise en œuvre de ces
nouveaux paramètres je vous remercie
monsieur directeur je laisse répondre à
aux Questions Nos rapporteurs ou merci
monsieur le Président merci aux de
rapporteurs pour le question question
très pertinente le effectivement on
avait eu l'occasion de discuter des
enjeux de certification des comptes et
je prends le Paris qu'on aura l'occasion
d'en rediscuter quel que soit
l'évolution peut-être peut-être sur la
base de votre question rappeler à
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
que effectivement nous avons un système
qui génère et j'y faisais allusion un
certain nombre d'erreurs déclaratives
c'estàd que le sujet c'est les erreurs
de ce qu'on appelle les données en
30in les déclarations de nos de nos nos
allocataires c'est pas la qualité des
comptes en tant que tel et ça la Cour
des comptes l'a indiqué nos comptes sont
bien tenus il y a pas de problème de
tenue des comptes financiers le sujet
c'est que nos comptes retracent
effectivement un certain nombre
d'erreurs résiduelles que nous mesurons
nous-mêmes parce que les indicateurs que
vous cité c'est nous qui les mesurons et
on les partage avec la cour donc on est
tout à fait d'accord avec l'analyse
qu'elle est faite simplement bien redire
que la dégradation que vous pointez elle
est réelle elle est le
fruit exclusivement d'un point de vue
statistique he mesure les facteurs
d'évolution euh de l'évolution de notre
panier de prestation versé c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait il y a eu deux changements
euh importants depuis 2019 il y a eu le
doublement de la prime d'activité suite
à la période dite gilet jaune et puis il
y a eu la réforme des aides au logement
à laquelle je faisais allusion
précédemment et en fait quand vous
regardez l'évolution des indicateurs
chaque prestation a un indicateur de
risque est plus ou moins risqué selon la
la la complexité de la prestation et et
du coup le niveau d'erreur que ça peut
engendrer euh dans les déclarations et
donc en fait ces deux prestations la
prestation de la prime d'activité d'une
prestation qui présente euh un volume
important de risque c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on va faire la réforme de la
solidarité à la source et donc quand
vous doublez du jour au lendemain la
prime d'activité vous augmentez vous
doublez le volume financier qui est
concerné par ces risques c'est-à-dire
que hips facto si le gouvernement avait
je je pense que c'était pas l'orentation
mais s'il avait divisé par deux la prime
d'activité à ce moment-là on serait
devenu largement meilleur du jour au
lendemain sans rien faire euh sur la
prise de le risque parce qu'en fait on
nous aurait si on avait supprimé la
priseactivité on aurait été d'un coup
excellent sur ce sujet voilà donc c'est
pour vous dire la le côté relatif un peu
de ces mesures ça veut pas dire que
c'est le sujet n'existe pas c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça j''y reviendrai qu'on
fait la solidarité à la source mais la
dégradation est en fait le refl de ça et
le reflet que sur l'aide au logement on
est passé comme vous le savez d'une aide
qui était calculée sur des revenus
fiscaux de 2 ans avant hein qui était du
coup assez inerte par rapport à
l'évolution des ressources à des
ressources beaucoup plus contemporaines
puisqueon se base sur les 12 derniers
mois glissant euh connu désormais en en
continu euh et donc ce faisant on est
passé d'une prestation extrêmement
simple et extrêmement sûre puisqu'il
suffisait de reporter sa case de d'impôt
2 ans avant à une déclaration à
prestation plus compliquée par cette
contemporanéité et plus compliqué parce
que les ressources qu'on connaît de
manière contemporaine ne sont pas
exhaustives par rapport euh au l de
logement ce qui fait qu'on a rajouté des
modules déclaratifs sur certaines
ressources qu'on connaît pas donc on a
rendu cette prestation pour des bonnes
raisons encore une fois et c'est une
réforme qui est intéressante et guidée
par la logique et bon sens de dire il
faut prendre les ressources les plus
contemporaines mais on a rendu les
indicateurs de risque beaucoup plus
importants sur cette prestation de de
logement qui est notre plus grosse
prestation donc l'évolution que retrace
la cour et c'est très très partagé avec
la cour il y a pas d'ambigué là-dessus
et le reflet de notre plan prestation
pour autant est-ce qu'il faut se dire
bah on en est là et on fait rien ou
est-ce qu'il faut dire justement il faut
attaquer le problème et essayer de
réduire considérablement le volume
d'erreur déclarative qui la réponse
évidemment on peut pas rester dans cette
situation et on a la vocation à verser
le juste droit et ni plus ni moins aux
allocataires d'où l'intérêt de la
réforme de la solidarité ressources
puisque si elle va pas résoudre tous les
problèmes d'un coup d'un seul elle va
notamment sur la prime d'activité et sur
le RSA qui est une autre prestation un
volume d'erreur très très important elle
va nous permettre de simplifier encore
une fois beaucoup la vie des gens et de
leur dire c'est ça que vous vouvez
déclarer et les gens ils vont évidemment
logiquement déclarer euh on le repartage
puisque c'est les bonnes la bonne façon
de calculer les ressources et donc on
aura moins besoin et pour certains
égards sur cette partie des ressources
plus besoin de venir vérifier expost des
erreurs qui ont été commises par nos
allocataires et donc on devrait avoir
des résultats très significatif
là-dessus pour autant ces résultats ne
viendront que progressivement puisque
vous vous parliez d'un indicateur à 24
mois c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 24 mois
d'écart dans la mesure de ce qui reste
comme erreur résiduelle et donc ça veut
dire qu'on va continuer encore à gérer
leancien système de toute façon encore
quelques années et donc on est engagé
sur un plan d'amélioration de la qualité
sur ce système là la Cour des comptes
pour vous simplifier sa vision il vous
le direz mieux que moi mais dans son
message qu'elle parté avec la non
certification C dire la priorité c'est
de faire la solidarité à la source il
faut le faire et donc il faut pas lâcher
cette réforme et elle a voulu maintenir
une sorte de pression aussi avec son sa
position pour autant on partage avec
elle l'idée qu'entreetemps il faut faire
d'autres choses et donc on a un plan
d'amélioration de la qualité voilà
transversal qu'on mène avec l'ensemble
des équipes que je pourrais je peut-être
pas épiloguer là mais on pourra y
revenir au printemps peut-être à
l'occasion de la certification des
comptes j'espère par par la Cour pour
vous expliquer un peu toutes les
démarches qu'on a qu'on a mené
simplement ces démarches elles sont
aussi elles doivent être aussi facilité
par le la le retour qu'on souhaite à de
meilleurs indicateurs de qualité de
service vous savez que depuis la réforme
des a de logement on a eu deux années
assez compliquées et que dans ce
contexte là bah on souhaite rendre le
service le mieux possible le plus vite
possible mais qu'on est aussi dans ce
contexte là parfois plus en difficulté
pour faire des vérifications des
contrôles et cetera de au même niveau
donc là le retour progressif à une
meilleure situation qui est actif hein
nous permet aussi de dégager davantage
de moyens sur sur ces sujets donc ça
fait partie des réponses qu'on pourra
vous apporter qu'on apportera évidemment
à la cour dans les dans les discussions
voilà sur les sujets financiers pour
répondre au rapporteur Monsieur H sur
les projections du gouvernement
évidemment les on les partage sont posé
elles sont elles sont assez claires vous
avez cité l'évolution l'année dernière
qui avait fait un un différentiel
relativement sensible sur ces sujets la
COG elle est calculée au sein de cette
trajectoire hein donc elle est conforme
à la trajectoire qui vous a présenter
elle nous permet une amplification de
l'effort sur un certain nombre de sujets
comme je je le mentionnais tout à
l'heure et comme vous redisiez à
l'instant sur les établissements
d'accueil des jeunes enfants donc je
pense qu'on a les moyens dans la
trajectoire qui est dessinée tel qu'elle
est là
de porter une politique volontariste
conforme à ce qui a été négocié dans le
cadre de la de la convention d'objectif
et gestion alors effectivement quand on
fait plus 2 milliards sur les 5 ans plus
6 % par an sur le fond national d'action
sociale ce mouvement il est aussi
nécessaire cont tenu des conditions
d'inflation que vous décrivez c'estàd
que on a connu des décennies avec des
inflations beaucoup moins fortes et
j'avais envie de renverser un peu le
raisonnement c'est si on avait pas fait
cette évolution là dans le contexte de
l'inflation on aurait eu du coup des
placer en grande difficulté cont tenu
bah des coûts de l'évolution leur coûts
et puis de l'évolution nécessaire des
salaires pour accompagner et être
attractif dans des secteurs qui ont
parfois la peine à recruter et donc oui
on doit résoudre une équation qui est
pas simple mais que les montants qui
sont prévus doivent permettre de faire
qui à la fois d'accompagner l'inflation
d'accompagner l'évolution des salaires
en fait quand on détermine nos
évolutions on le fait sur un indice
mixte prix salaire he et donc qui
combine à la fois les effets d'infation
et les effets anticipés souhaité sur les
aspects salarios accompagner des
évolutions salariales notamment dans les
secteurs professionnels tels que la plus
petite enfance le gouvernement a annoncé
sa volonté d'accompagner avec nous et
avec nos financements les revalisation
salariales que les branches
professionnelles du secteur la petite
enfance doivent conclure dans les mois
qui viennent pour améliorer ça fait
partie de la qualité hein ce sujet de
d'attractivité des professionnels de la
présence des professionnels et la
rémunération du coup des professionnels
et donc accompagner ces mouvements là
accompagner un développement quantitatif
hein et donc de faire davantage de place
sur la petite enfance de faire davantage
de centres sociaux sur les territoires
qui on en besoin de faire davantage de
d'accueil périscolaire dans les communes
qui en sont dépourvu ou qui se sont pas
assez développés qui ont pas suivu le
mouvement démographique et donc on a
cette équation là qui nous permet de
faire ces différents mouvements
simultanément en tant que tel donc on
évolu les hausses sont nettement plus
importantes que l'inflation stricte
telle qu'elle est anticipée sur la
période pour répondre à votre à votre
question voilà et puis sur la le
complément mode de garde effectivement
donc c'est une réforme qui a été votée
l'année dernire dernière dans laquelle
on est engagé avec nos partenaires et
néanmoins amis de l'URSAF caisse
nationale avec lesquel on travaille très
étroitement puisque en fait on est en
partage le dispositif y compris pour
simplifier la vie des bénéficiaires et
des
employeurs de particulierers
emploi à domicile ou assistante
maternelle et donc on est engagé sur
cette exercice il a vocation
effectivement à aboutir à mi- 2025 parce
que c'est des sujets qui sont très
lourds en terme de pilotage de
changement et de simplification parce
que c'est toujours pareil he c'est que
on est des si vous permettez le
expression très techno on internalise la
complexité pour nos bénéficiaires et
donc en réalité la complexité il faut la
la gérer et donc précisément quand vous
dites je passe d'une aide forfaitaire
avec des tranches je passe à une aide
linéarisée c'est-à-dire proportionnelle
aux ressources des gens et aux salaires
qui sont versés bah c'est plus juste en
terme de modalité de recours
c'est-à-dire que vous avez vous allez
ouvrir des modes d'accueil des jeunes
enfants qui sont aujourd'hui
financièrement pas juridiquement mais
financièrement interdits à des
populations précaire au fragile donc
c'est très intéressant en terme
d'égalité d'accès à une forme de d'offre
et service public de la petite enfance
si on prend ces terme mais du coup vous
allez derrière avoir des formules de
calcul beaucoup plus complexes qu'on va
internaliser encore une fois les
bénéficiaires de la veront pas et donc
on doit gérer dans les systèmes
d'information d'où le délai qui est qui
est posé qui nécessite aussi des
ajustements par rapport à quelles sont
les évolutions et les impacts
individuels pour les familles et s
devait y avoir c'est possible quelques
perdant sur telle ou telle catégorie
comment comme pour le la h on neutralise
le temps ça va dur Mo longtemps que sur
la h parce que les enfants n'ont pas
vocation à être gardés éternellement non
plus mais on neutralise quand même les
effets donc y a quand même un dispositif
assez complexe à mettre en place et donc
qui qui a vocation à à s'appliquer en
septembre 2025 ce qui permet aussi aussi
avec la rentrée de septembre de de faire
la jointure avec des moments où les
enfants sortent des modes d'accueil ce
qui est probablement plus pertinent que
de le faire en juillet qui qui
obligerait à mettre en place un
dispositif complexe pour de mois pour
pour la transition voilà donc d'où les
ajustements qui sont en cours sur les
sur les dates sur sur ces sujets merci
beaucoup je vais maintenant donner la
parole à Pascal
gruni merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur moi je voulais
vous interroger sur la fraude oui est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous donner des
indications en fait plus moins voilà une
évaluation peut-être sachant que c'est
c'est de la frotte donc on sait pas mais
c'est surtout est-ce que est-ce qu'on
avance sur sur le sujet parce que bon
c'est toujours difficile à évaluer mais
en fait quand on trouve de la frotte
c'est de l'argent quand même qui nous
manque pour aider des des personnes qui
en ont vraiment besoin euh
ensuite j'étais rapporteur sur pour le
le texte de loi plein emploi donc
j'aurais voulu connaître votre position
savoir quel changement pour vous dans
l'article 10 vraiment concrètement et
sur l'article 10 bis qui est sur le
contrôle comment en fait vous vous
positionnez vous à travers cette
nouvelle organisation merci merci
beaucoup
annieouerou merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le directeur pour ce qui
nous concerne le PLFSS 2024 nous laissz
sur notre fin quant à la politique
familiale mais vous semblez satisfait de
la Cuse signée en juillet 2023 donc qui
vous donnerait des marges de manœuvre
pour assurer donc l'accompagnement des
familles donc pourquoi l'augmentation
des prestations
familiales est prévu au 1er avril
2024 seulement alors que l'inflation on
la connaî
les familles
seraient en en demande d'une
d'une réévaluation de ces prestations
sur la petite enfance est-ce que
l'objectif de 100000 places en
2027 reste un objectif atteignable dans
dans vos prévisions et puis une question
concernant les points info jeunesse je
crois qu'ils sont
désormais financés par la CAF est-ce
que cette nouvelles dépenses a donné
lieu à un budget supplémentaire si oui à
la ur des besoins et est-ce que donc
est-ce qu'il y a eu un transfert en fait
du budget de l'État ou est-ce que c'est
a été négocié aussi dans le cadre de la
coche donc c'est une information voilà
euh et puis une dernière question
concernant le segéure pour tous les
personnels de descaf mais aussi des
associations qui interviennent dans le
champ de
l'enfance pour tout ce qui concerne les
postes administratif et technique ont
été exclus du Ségur et ça crée un des
tension social dans certains
établissements est-ce qu'il est question
de est-ce qu'il serait question de
revaloriser aussi ses métiers au même
titre que les métiers plus techniques et
et donc est-ce que c'est ces évolution
qui tendrait à à à temporiser à
revaloriser aussi ses métiers serait
d'actualité merci beaucoup Laurent
burgois
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur j'auraai deux questions à à
vous poser l'une sur la petite enfance
l'autre sur les centres sociaux
concernant la la petite enfance vous
avez évoqué mais j'aimerais y revenir en
complément de la question de Pascal
grenier sur le qualitatif et notamment
par rapport à la médiatisation depuis
quelques mois de certains fonctionnement
de de certaines crèche euh quelle
décision laacnaf a prise ou ou compte
prendre pour per à cela concernant les
les centres sociaux euh avec
l'expérience d'élu local que j'ai pu
avoir ne pensez-vous pas que contte tenu
des des récentes tmeutes qu'il y a eu
dans dans notre pays il y a quelques
mois il serait intéressant de de voir
comment amplifier l'ouverture de
certains centres sociaux dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville avec
une bonification que pourrait apporter
la la CAF oui de département par rapport
au fonctionnement de ces centres
sociaux merci beaucoup maredou
schlman merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur merci pour toutes
les réponses que vous nous avez apporté
deux questions la première concerne la
petite enfance alors peut-être que je
vais vous prendre au dépourvu mais vous
pourrez nous faire parvenir les
questions enfin les réponses par la
suite je voudrais connaître s'il vous
plaît euh le coût consolidé de la de
l'accueil de la prise en charge d'un
enfant à l'extérieur de sa famille alors
en prenant en compte bien sûr toutes les
déductions les différents compléments et
les allocations et euh et les
contributions de la CAF et par rapport
au coût de la prise en charge par sa
famille c'est-à-dire à travers le le
congé parental pour avoir un peu une
idée de de la de ce que représente
chaque chaque modalité de prise en
charge ma deuxème question concerne plus
précisément le l'accueil périscolaire et
et extrascolaire donc parmi les les
objectifs de la convention d'objectifs
et de gestion 2023 2027 entre la CAF et
l'État figure l'ambition numéro 2 qui
est de favoriser l'accueil périscolaire
et extrascolaire des jeunes enfants avec
notamment le recrutement ou en tout cas
la mise à disposition de plus 410
animateurs qualifiés alors nous
intervenons dans un ça tout cela
intervient dans un contexte de de
raréfaction de la ressource en personnel
d'animation qualifié puisque les commun
commun le subissent et le connaissent
donc deux questions l'enquête 2003 qui a
été faite par l'Association des maires
de France révèle notamment une forme de
disparité entre les petites et les
grandes communes en ce qui concerne la
possibilité d'offrir à tous les enfants
un accueil périscolaire et extrascolaire
de qualité avec la question du reste à
charge qui reste pour les communes nous
savons très bien que les pour les
grandes communes on arrive à peu près à
faire face mais pour les petites
communes notamment celles de moins de
2000 habit temps c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué ça pose une question de
d'égalité de traitement entre toutes les
communes sur le territoire d'une part et
le deuxième point c'est
plutôt savoir sur la question du
recrutement et la disponibilité de
personnel qualifi pour pour travailler
dans dans les accueils de loisirs
qu'est-ce que vous envisagez pour
faciliter d'abord l'atractivité
améliorer l'attractivité de ses postes
d'une part et puis faire en sorte qu'on
a davantage de personnel qualifié et le
deuxème point concerne plutôt
l'inclusion vous faites état d'un bonus
financier inclusion handicap je sais que
le président est particulièrement engagé
et attentif à ces questions euh en quoi
ça consiste exactement et et deuxième
question pardon pour toutes ces
questions successives comment vous le
prenez en compte comment vous le prenez
en compte quand on sait qu'il y a une
dualité de recrutement entre l'éducation
nationale et les communes d'autre part
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'une
unif
de la du process de recrutement serait
plus facile pour mettre en œuvre cette
cette politique d'inclusion dans
l'accueil périscolaire qui est une
continuité éducative importante pour la
prise en charge de l'enfant merci pour
ces deux
questions qualifé qualifé quand on aime
on ne compte
pas faut toujours des preuves d'amour
aussi très bien merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur merci
pour cet
exposé moi je voulais revenir sur la CTG
que vous aviez voulu il y a 2 ans
généraliser en tout cas au maximum et et
signé avec les les les métropoles et et
collectivités
euh et EPCI pardon quelle est son
incidence financière et quel est son
objectif Infiné euh en d'autres termes
il y a certains dispositifs qui en font
partie aujourd'hui et je suppose que
vous allez étendre dans cette CTG à
d'autres
à d'autres dispositifs les 1000 jours
entre autres et ce est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un mot très bien moi
j'auris une dernière question en tant
que président de la commission je suis
en ce moment c'est un point d'actualité
très fortement solliicité par les
centres sociaux dans les applications
des des accords des accords de branche
avec notamment les revalations
salariales et la question qui est posée
c'est est-ce que il y a une a financière
prévue pour les accompagner dans cette
transformation très bien merci monsieur
le Président merci à toutes et tous pour
ces deux questions et demi euh
auxquelles je vais essayer de répondre
progressivement et si si c'est pas le
cas on raer à mes devoirs euh mais elle
croise toutes pas mal nos sujets
effectivement d'actualité et d'enjeux
d'enjeux très fort euh donc vous avez
été quelques-uns parler de la question
de la lutte contre la fraude euh donc
vous dire que euh la branche famille est
très très engagé sur ces sujets et je
dois dire assez reconnu euh je dis avec
beaucoup de modestie donc je'y suis pour
rien donc je je permets de le souligner
vous faisiez état du fait que la Cour
des comptes était pas forcément
toujours indulgente sur un certain
nombre de sujets et sur la sur la lutte
contre la fraude elle est plutôt à
saluer ce que fait la branche famille de
manière générale à la fois sur
l'évaluation de la fraude c'està-dire la
quantification de la fraude on a un
modèle assez poussé assez ancien
désormais et assez peu répandu pour
avoir fait un échange autour du ministre
chargé des comptes publics récemment sur
sur ces sujets d'évaluation de la fraude
par des enquêtes quê et par des enquêtes
aléatoires c'estàd qu'on va tous les 2
ans procéder à un certain nombre de
contrôle exhaustif de dossierers déjà
contrôlé pas contrôler pour évaluer
l'impact de la fraude et du coup
extrapoler son impact global ce qui nous
permet d'estimer à environ 2 milliards
l'impact de la fraude de manière
générale ce qui nous ce qui est
important sur à peu près 100 milliards
de de prestations ce qui est beaucoup
moins important que les erreurs qu'on a
listé tout à l'heure et on voit bien que
le sujet c'est pas pour relativiser le
sujet fraude c'est pour dire que on est
dans un emble plus large de comment on
fait le juste droit hein et que euh nos
nos réformes que j'ai évoqué tout
l'heure j'y reviens pas vous nous aidez
à lutter contre les erreurs mais vont
aussi nous aidez à lutter contre la
fraude parce que quand vous avez une
déclaration préremplie qui vous dit
voilà ce que je sais de vos ressources
vous êtes aussi un peu moins tenter euh
d'aller cacher telle ou telle ressource
parce que vous voyez que
l'administration a déjà des informations
donc tout ça ira dans le même sens pour
autant d'orsz déjà dans le système
actuel et puis on va évidemment
continuer on a un certain nombre
d'action très très fortes sur ces sujets
700 contrôleurs France entière engagé
sur ces enjeux de lutte contre la fraude
et depuis 2 ans mais on avait l'occasion
de la présenter dans cette commission un
service national de lutte contre la
fraude en jeu euh à ce stade d'une
trentaine de d'inspecteurs mais qui va
voilà augmenter de quelques quinzaines
d'unités dans les dans les semaines qui
viennent puisque ça fait partie des
renforcements actés dans le cadre de la
convention d'objectif et de gestion euh
pour non pas faire le même travail que
z00 mais pour en fait intervenir sur la
fraude organisée ce qu'on appelle la
fraude en jeu la fraude structurée donc
souvent les allocataires sont victimes
plus cuteur en réalité on a des
allocataires dans la frude plus
individuelle qui peuvent fruder en nous
cachant tel revenu en nous cachant telle
situation familiale et cetera ça fait
partie des choses qu'on va continuer
évidemment à contrôler et sur lesquelles
on sera encore vigilant mais on voit
bien que ce qui se développe c'est la
fraude en jeu c'est des systèmes
organisés de d'usurpation d'identité
d'usurpation de RIB sur les réseaux
sociaux sur d'autres systèmes de
systèmes assez sophistiqués parfois de
fauses micro-entreprises avec des
fausses déclarations vous avez quand
même des gens qui créent des faux
salariés qui payent des vraies
cotisations mais pour récupérer des
aides supérieures évidemment cotisation
qui payent donc c'est des systèmes quand
même très sophistiqués et on a en avec
ce service national recruter des experts
venant des impôts venant de banques
venant de Service de police de
gendarmerie pour croiser un peu les
expertises sur ces sujets et on a d'ors
et déjà des résultats très intéressants
en la matière qui vont monter en
puissance en en ce développant donc on
est vraiment très actif sur sur ces
sujets et on aura l'occasion de vous
présenter les bilan si si vous le
souhaitez mais de capacité
d'amplification de réponses après ça
reste évidemment partiel par rapport à
tout ce qu'on tout ce qui peut exister
mais on voit bien que cette fraude en
jeu elle a aussi un impact financier
beaucoup plus important et donc si vous
débusquez les les phénomènes le plusut
tôt possible bah vous limitez l'impact
financier je prends un exemple sur les
fraudes horribes euh désormais dans 80 %
des cas on ne on fait aucun paiement
c'estàdire qu'il y a zéro versement
parce qu'on interrompt le processus
avant le premier versement parce que des
gens qui sont un peu organisés en
général on a du mal à récupérer l'argent
quand on a identifié la fraude quand on
quand c'est de la fraude plus
individuelle ou des des prestations des
gens peut de tricher et cetera commment
on leur va continuer à leur verser des
prestations en général on récupère assez
facilement les sommes parcequon se sert
sur nos propres prestations des gens qui
organisent la fraude et qui organisent
le contournement c'est en général
beaucoup plus difficile et puis y a la
fraude AR les résidences qui est un
élément très important je mentionné tout
à l'heure sur lequel le ministre Gabriel
Atal avait annoncé un certain nom de
mesures qui commencent à se à se
décliner j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
l'harmonisation des conditions de
résidence et de d'exigence de 9 mois de
sesjours sur le territoire national on a
là aussi un système par notre service
national de lutte contre fraude en jeu
de détection des situations de fraude à
la résidence qui est de plus en plus
efficace et qui nous permet de de bien
de mieux lutter contre ces phénomènes
donc il a encore du travail évidemment
mais soyez assurés qu'on est très actif
sur sur ces sujets alors vous avez été
nombreux à parler de petites enfants je
vais essayer de regrouper et on essay
n'oublier mais regrouper un certain
nombre de de de réponses euh donc
premièrement par rapport au projet de
loi voilà en fin d'examen le pour nous
l'article 10 est important parce qu'il
clarifie les éléments de gouvernance
local euh sur la petite enfance qui
était aujourd'hui un peu un peu diffus
il pose en autorité organisatrice il
pose une responsabilité une organisation
il nous pose également c'est plus
discret dans dans le texte mais c'est
quand même écrit il nous pose en rôle
branche famille de soutien à ce service
public de la petite enfance et comme je
disais tout à l'heure soutien financier
nous les moyens de la COG mais soutien
aussi en ingénierie en conseil en
présence territoriale et c'est ce que
font les beaucoup les cfes je reviendrai
sur les conventions territoriales
globales tout à l'heure euh parce que
quand quand on est vous parliez euh je
crois madame hasliman de des différences
de taille entre collectivité euh selon
la la structuration la capacité
d'ingénierie locale on peut avoir des
fortes différences aussi très fortes les
métropoles qui ont pas besoin beaucoup
d'appui sur ces sujets il y a des
territoires qui ont besoin de beaucoup
plus d'appui et puis quand vous créez
euh une crèche par an sur euh c'est pas
pareil que vous avz créé une pour la
première fois et donc du coup vous avez
besoins de conseil de méthodologie de
mise en relation aussi avec des acteurs
et donc on perçoit vraiment le rôle le
cave dans cette logique on n'est pas du
coup dans une logique concurrentielle en
disant ah bah c'est maintenant c'est les
collectivités locales nous on s'en
occupe c'est vraiment on est dans une
logique d'appui de développement de
conseil dans le prolongement de ce qu'on
fait déjà mais avec des responsabilités
mieux clarifiées et un positionnement
assez clair de notre côté le texte a
aussi repris dans la version ici de la
commission B paritaire l'idée que pour
simplifier un peu aussi la vie
collectivité le les nouveaux schémas qui
sont posés en terme d' rgation peuvent
être l'obligation peut être remplie par
le passage par la convission
territoriale globale ce qui permet aussi
de pas multiplier les textes et les
documents un peu parallèles alors qu'on
a la les schémas alors que finalement on
peut avoir la même vocation et le même
esprit donc je trouve que c'est une
bonne simplification qui a apportée dans
cette dans cette rédaction et on est
aussi trèsp partie prenante sur
l'article 10 bis sur les contrôles parce
qu'on est on a une politique active de
contrôle très centrée sur nos
compétences donc plutôt sur les aspects
financiers hein parce que les aspects
plus qualitatifs sont plutôt du ressort
de la PMI du département pour autant ce
qu'on perçoit et on le perçoit sur des
bonnes pratiques qui existent dans un
certain nombre de territoirees c'est que
la bonne articulation de ces différentes
modalités de contrôle est en fait
essentiel c'est-à-dire qu'on peut avoir
des capacités d'identification de
détection de problèmes qui viennent par
le volet financier mais qui en fait
traduisent un problème plus qualitatif
ça peut se faire sous l'angle inverse
aussi et donc nous on est très partie
prenante et très volontaire pour
travailler de manière articuler la main
dans la main avec l'ENSEM de partenaires
en général c'est dans cet esprit mais ça
méritait peut-être une relance un peu
territoriale de ces sujets
d'articulation et donc l'article 10 B
s'inscrit dans cette logique là il nous
permettra aussi de développer nos
propres pouvoirs de contrôle sur
notamment des groupes là où on est
parfois un peu limité quand on est à une
échelle départementale où en fait la
politique est fixée par un groupe de
crèche à l'échelle nationale et donc
l'entité locale elle peut pas
grand-chose et on voit bien que parfois
ça peut être intéressant de regarder
plusieurs crèches du même groupe à dans
plusieurs départements et donc ce regard
national va être facilité par le texte
qui est qui est posé en la matière
autrement on se horte un petit peu aux
politiques de groupe et ça va nous
permettre aussi de nous inscrire dans
une logique de lutte contre la fraude
aussi sur ces sujets euh d'action
sociale parce qu'en réalité aujourd'hui
une structure peut faire des erreurs de
la même façon que parce que c'est
parfois des règles aussi assez complexes
et ça on corrige les erreurs on discute
voilà mais il y a certains cas où c'est
ça va chercher dans l'intentionnalité ça
va chercher dans la fraude et en réalité
notre arsenal de réponse est pas est
moins fort sur les structures qu'il ne
laisse sur les individus c'est-à-dire
que on rétablit ce qu'on la relation
financière telle qu'elle aurait dû être
mais on va pas beaucoup plus loin là on
va pouvoir avir prendre des sanctions
administratives là où aujourd'hui la
seule le seul outil c'est d'aller au
pénal et on sait que le pénal c'est
parfois incertain sur des préjudices qui
sont importants pour nous maiselle de à
l'échelle de la société peut être
considéré comme pas prioritaire et donc
la réponse pénale est quand même très
longue et très incertaine une sanction
administrative ça peut être très
efficace donc on est là aussi très
intéressé par les développement de cette
de cet article la question a été posée
parou sur la nombre de
places donc l'objectif national global
il est de 100000 solutions he c'est pas
des places de crèche 100000 solutions
d'accueil supplémentaire à échéance 2027
ce qui passe notamment par des Accueils
Collectifs des acc collectif
supplémentaire et donc nous dans la dans
la convention d'objectif et de gestion
on a un objectif de 35000 places de
crèche pour le coup supplémentaire en
quand on fait la somme de ce qu'on fait
en plus et de ce qu'on fait en moins ce
qui va nous obliger cont tenu du fait
qu'il y a par ailleurs des fermetures
des pénuries personnel les difficultés à
certain nombre d'endroits pour créer
35000 places nettes il faut qu'on crée
plus de 60000 places brut en réalité he
qui rentre dans ce décompte global des
100000 donc on est dans un enjeu assez
fort on est dans une dynamique récente
qui est pas celle-là donc clairement ça
veut dire une amplification et une
accentuation de l'effort ça veut dire
travailler avec les collectivité locale
dans la logique du projet de loi qu'on
vient d'évoquer et travailler
madameévoqué sur un autre dossier surqu
je vais revenir mais travailler sur les
restes à charges des collectivités
compris sur la petite enfance et de se
dire comment on s'engage mutuellement
dans des développement lorsque c'est
nécessaire comment on peut faire un
effort nous supplémentaire pour que on a
des engagements et qu' puisse le faire
davantage sur des qui s'engage peut-être
davantage dans le développement donc
c'est la logique des conventions je
réponds pas à votre question mais je
réponds progressivement quand même la
logique des conventions territorial
global c'est aussi de faire du non non
non de dire bah la collectivité va
s'engager nous on va peut-être limiter
le reste à charge par place en disant
bah la CAF va mettre plus finalement
proportionnellement par place pour
limiter l'impact pour la collectivité
d'un effort nécessaire comp tenu de ses
besoins de population donc c'est des
logiques qu'on souhaite poursuivre on
avait besoin de la coge on avait besoin
de l'article 10 pour poser le cadre
parce que c'est vrai qu'autrement ça
créé de l'incertitude maintenant on va
pouvoir s'employer dans dans cette
démarche-là mais qui sera pas facile
pour les raisons financières certes mais
aussi beaucoup pour les raisons
professionnelles euh vous l'avez évoqué
les uns les autres de démographie sur
ces sur ces métiers euh qui sont pas
évidents mais on est très très résolu
sur sur ce sujet monsieur Bourgois
parler des sujets qualitatifs hein parce
que là on parle du quantitatif mais je
vous le disais le qualitatif est très
important pour nous tous euh on va
développer un certain nombre de leviers
financiers qui vont renforcer ce volet
qualitatif dans notre soutien aux
structures et aux collectivités qui que
se développe donc vous savez qu'on a un
financement à l'activité qui s'appelle
la prestation de service unique la PSU
qu'on va qui va continuer à augmenter
dans dans la période mais qui va être
complété par une montée en charge plus
rapide des bonus qu'on peut faire sur
certains territoire des bonus liés à la
qualité des bonus liés à la
revalorisation des rémunérations dans
les branches professionnelles ce qui
fait que ce qu'on souhaite c'est qu'on
rééquilibre progressivement les choses
et que les pars lié à des bonus plus
forfaitaires soient prenent une place
plus importante dans les années qui
viennent et donc aide à la qualité parce
que quand on a un financement direct sur
la qualité ou un financement à
l'amélioration des rémunération on
contribue à ces logiques de qualité
quand on vient sur les financements à
l'investissement la réhabilitation d'un
certain nombre de lieu d'accueil on voit
bien que ça contribue aussi aux
conditions de travail et et à la qualité
et donc tout ça pour nous on on souhaite
surtout pas opposer quantité et qualité
parce que en fait il y a des besoins des
deux côtés et donc c'est sur ces deux
sujets qu'on continue à à travailler je
n'ai pas la réponse sur sur sur le coût
consolidé que Madame me demandé vous en
doutiez j'aurais bien aimé vous
surprendre mais j'ai pas forcément les
éléments précis on va y travailler avec
quand même quelques réserves que je mets
sur le raisonnement parce que je pense
qu'on peut pas que raisonner sur cette
logique purement financière derrière
dans le sens où un certain nombre de
travaux académiques éprouvés pas par
nous mais montre l'intérêt de la
socialisation et l'intérêt des modes
d'accueil collectif à un moment donné
aussi et que la il peut y avoir une
combinatoire c'est pas c'est d'ailleurs
tout le débat autour du conget parental
plus court et mieux indemnisé il peut y
avoir une combinatoire dans un parcours
d'enfance des mil premiers jours entre
une période avec la famille peut-être un
peu plus longue que seul congé maternité
et des périodes d'accueil collectif qui
contribue aussi à la socialisation et au
développement de l'enfant c'est vraiment
scientifiquement démontré et je pense
important et je pense en particulier
dans certaines populations fragile en
difficulté et cetera qui sont peut-être
les populations qui aujourd'hui accèdent
le plus facilement au conget parental
plus long moins rémunéré parce que
s'exclurant du marché du travail ou
n'entrant pas sur le marché du travail
ce qui peut avoir des enfin c'est pour
ça que je je je relativise aussi le le
sens de votre question mais sans la
contester mais on peut se dire ça coûte
moins cher de faire ça mais ça aussi
peut-être un coût dans la nons
socialisation de l'enfant et dans
l'éloignement du marché du travail euh
de la personne et donc le raisonnement
il serait vraiment à raisonner à coût
complet et avec des coûts qu'on peut pas
complètement estimer sur l'impact pour
la société de de de C cet éloignement je
dirais mais euh on pourra travailler
quelques ques éléments complémentaires
sur finan tout à fait tout à fait tout à
fait mais c'est pour vous les
interpréterai à l'Ô de ce que j'ai pu
compléter comm élément de de contexte je
termine sur petite enfance mais je pense
que j'ai un peu près fait le tour alors
centre sociau par raison de rappeler
votre question monsieur le
Président a quelques encore le centres
sociaux oui on est très partenaire
évidemment de ce secteur on est très
impliqué dans le développement
territorial des centres sociaux on avait
un objectif dans la prééson de COG qu'on
a pas complètement tenu pas pour des
raisons qui ne tiennent qu'à nous mais
sur lequel on a quand même très
significativement avancé qui de
couverture notamment des territoires
fragiles quartier prioritaire de la
politique de la ville par des lieux
centres sociaux espace de la vie sociale
et c'est un un des sujets sur lesquel on
a connu des résultats quand même très
intéressants on souhaite finaliser cette
couverture territoriale dans cette
nouvelle coge ça implique de pouvoir
accompagner le développement et donc
pouvoir accompagner les structures
existantes y compris sur les aspects de
coût euh parce qu'elles sont impacté
comme tout le monde par l'inflation et
puis par les coûts salariaux parce que
ça fait partie des sujets d'attractivité
sur ces métiers sur ses actcteur et de
convention collectives qui s'engag
là-dessus donc oui la conventionobjectif
gestion elle ne prévoit pas une n
directe liée à l'évolution de la
rémunération comme le secteur de petite
enfance parce que dans la petite enfance
il y a une forme de de comment dire de
carotte àoser pour des négociations qui
ont pas encore eu lieu et qui concernent
plusieurs branches différentes et dire B
vous en fait on vous donnera l'aide
quand vous vous aurez revalorisé ça a
déjà avancé côté ces sociaux donc on
sait de quoi on parle c'est plus simple
à certains égards et donc la dynamique
financière qu'on a sur le poste
animation de la vie sociale qui couvre
les centres sociaux va nous permettre de
mieux accompagner y compris l'évolution
des coûts salariaux dans ce dans ce
secteur et la poursuite du développement
territorial qu'on souhaite faire je
pense que dans la question de Monsieur
Bourgois il y avait le sujet d'amplifier
comme vous disiez amplification c'est
horair y compris sur les horreurs
d'ouverture he c'est ça alors c'est un
sujet qui a déjà été pas mal testé qui
qui est pas simple le capable produit
des impacts très très massifs sur sur
ces sujets dans le dans le il y a
quelques années une action forte
là-dessus car c'est pas traduite par des
choses très spectaculaires mais on voit
bien qui ça interroge globalement le
modèle sur comment on est là au bon
endroit et au bon moment pour les
publics euh et avec les bonnes activités
les bonnes réponses familiales et
destiné aux jeunes en particulier et
donc après c'est des choses qui peuvent
aussi se travailler localement et
paraêtre dans un modèle unique national
en la matière mais on voit bien
l'intérêt du sujet quoi voilà vous m
interrogz
je sur les sujets jeunesse pardon je je
suis un peu long mais j'essaie de pas
frustrer personne dans les dans les
réponses sur les sujets jeunesse et
enfance donc enfance avec les les sujets
de périscolaire qui ont été évoqué par
Man schliman en particulier oui on est
très attaché à cette politique on est
très conscient je le disais que la la
conciliation vie familiale
professionnelle va plus loin et que les
sujets de socialisation des enfants
passent aussi par ces ctant périscolaire
et extrascolaire on était quelque peu
limité dans la précédente convention
d'objectif et de gestion puisque c'est
des volume financier qui étaient assez
figés et qui ont pas permis poursuivre
le développement et qui du coup peuvent
avoir un tout petit peu gravé dans le
mar des inégalités que vous mentionnez
c'est-à-dire que des communes plus
petites ou plus moins structuré qui
auraient pas déjà développé ne pouvaent
pas failelle développait dans la période
elle développait sans notre soutien donc
le reste à charge était du coup plus
important le reste à charge grosso modo
dans ce secteurs il est nous on prend à
peu près 20 % des dépenses he sur ce
sujet donc c'est moins fort que sur la
petite enfance où on est à plus de 50 %
de de financement c'est c'est moins fort
que sur les centres sociauxù on est
aussi assez largement premier financeur
mais on est c'est pas àoda 20 % de de
prise en charge donc dans la nouvelle
coge là aussi on a une dynamique
financière qui va nous permettre de
reprendre ce développement et
d'accompagner en particuler les communes
qui qu'on a pas pu accompagner ces
dernières années sur sur ces sujets on
va permettre aussi la création du bonus
inclusion handicap donc c'est une
avancée forte qui a été annoncée par le
président de la République à la
conférence nationale du du handicap euh
sur des choses qu'on avait poussé
précédemment puisqueon l'a fait sur les
crèches depuis quelques années et donc
c'est simplement enfin je rentre pas
dans la mécanique technique mais c'est
simplement une majoration financière
liée au nombre d'enfants en situation de
handicap dès le premier enfant euh qu'on
majeur déjà pour les crèches on l'avait
expérimenté sur quelques départements
sur les accueils de loisirs sur la
précédente coge on voulait le
généraliser ça a été décidé c'est prévu
dans la coge et donc ça va pouvoir se
mettre en place dans les dans les
semaines qui viennent on a passé dans
nos instances il y a quelques il a
quelques jours donc on est en cours de
déclinaison sur ce sujet en prenant en
compte l'impact le surcout c'est très
compliqué on est obligé de moyenniser un
petit peu mais le surcout moyen que ça
génère d'accueillir un enfant en
situation de handicap pour que ça
neutralise la problématique financière
c'est pas la seule problématique mais ça
sur ces sur ces accueils et der mot
Monsieur le Directeur est-ce que je peux
me permettre une deux questions
extrêmement rapides il nous reste 3
minutes elle est toute petite ma
question c'est simplement pour rebondir
sur les propos que vous avez tenus tout
à l'heure concernant le la fraude et
pour rebondir sur la question de de ma
collègue Pascal grenny je voulais savoir
quelle était la part du budget qui était
consacré aujourd'hui au contrôle de la
fraude merci et Madame pourséong toute
petiteion vous avez parlé
dans les 100000 solutions d'accueil
supplémentaire qu même désormais ça il y
avit 35000 crêch net puis après vous
avez dit il en faut 60000 crêches brut
pour pour avoir une finé 35000 net mais
vous avez dit dans les 100000 c'est
60000 les 60000 sont les 100000 ouais ça
veut dire qu'on a que
75000 solutions d'accueil supplémentaire
net
[Musique]
la réponse plusie
directeur très court il Ava de questions
j' pas répondu de Madame sur la
rorisation des prestations familiales
c'est prévu comme ça c'est un sujet
plutôt gouvernement si vous souhaitez
poser la question mais on respecte les
dates qui sont prévues les Pag ça c'est
fait sur la les plans d'accueil je s
fait sur la précédente convenionobjectif
gestion la bascule donc on a récupéré la
gestion sur les financements branche
famille par contre dans la nouvelle coge
on a des moyens supplémentaires sur
cette ligne pour pouvoir structurer
quelque part on a récupéré un dispositif
tel qu'il était on va structurer
doctrine nationale et une règle
nationale stratégie comme on a sur les
autres secteurs qu'on avait pas encore
fait précédemment sur ce secteur donc ça
va être des développements intéressants
je pense sur cette cette thématique
là et sur le le segure globalement il y
a plus de généralisation des segures sur
les personnels CAF puisque vous parlez
des personnel CAF nous on a un projet
j'ai une volonté de négocier la
classification la convention collective
quoi grosso modo dans le secteur de la
sécurité sociale de manière générale
avec en tête certains sujet issu du
segure notamment sur les travailleurs
sociaux parce que ça fait partie des des
enjeux qui étaient qui étaient portés
sur le sujet fraude je peux pas vous
répondre là non plus précisément je vous
ai dit 700 contrôleurs par exemple sur
35000 salariés grosso modo c'est pas
c'est pas anoda voilà sur la part du
budget je pourrais vous répondre plus
précisément sur le décompte je je suis
pas sûr d'avoir compris votre calcul
mais simplement grosso modo il y a des
modes d'accueil collectifs il y a des
modes d'accueil individuels voilà dans
ce qui relève des modes d'accueil
collectif on va compter de l'ensemble
des créations parce qu'en fait créer une
place c'est un effort considérable et
donc on va créer compter de l'ensemble
des créations brutes quelque part donc
de l'ordre de 60000 parmi les 60000 brut
voilà et après il y a de l'accueil
individuel c'est ça que j'ai pas compris
non mais on pourra prendre 5 minutes à
côté si vous si vous le souitez
Monsieur le Directeur merci on a un
timing un peu seré bien sû peu BAV mais
on va madame ministre heureusement qu'
pas d'actualité non non merci
beaucoup
bien sûr